today we are doing an incredibly unfair
photo comparison between the new iPhone
11 Pro max and the original iPhone shops
over here we need to leave I'm gonna
start chopping I'm gonna sit like this
no no okay your finger here just in
front of the camera like that's weird
I can't get the whole shot you gotta
back up I love this so much
yes sir whoa it's so small so we looked
it up just to confirm this original
iPhone is a 2 megapixel camera and the
new iPhone 11 Pro 12 it's false I might
want to retake this but yeah it looks
like I fell asleep can you look back a
little further yeah
[Music]
the best thing I've ever done of it this
looks like trash this used to be the
norm like this was incredible at its
time and it really is kind of crazy to
see where we started from and where we
are
I cannot wait to do a comparison of a
night shot versus the original iPhone
it's gonna look like it took inside of a
plastic bag that's Jenna yes Jenna chill
Jenna this is Jenna Oh Jen you look
really pixelated you look like a
2-megapixel potato God put your arm up
[Music]
this is seriously I cannot believe up
terrible desoto looks this could be
anybody with brown hair looks like you
took this in 1999 this is where Apple
got the inspiration for the iPhone 11
midnight green color so I think for the
only fair thing to do is to do a
comparison between the front-facing
camera there was a technique that I used
to use to take a photo of yourself so I
would go like this I would line my
finger up with the button and then I
would hold it out and then I would know
that the button is just about right
there
[Music]
Wow I look like I'm from 2007 Oh Jenna
this is a cute pic I'm actually zooming
in with the 2x telephoto camera to get
the same distance as the original phone
[Music]
I'm gonna get closer to Jenna so I can
actually see her face in this photo
you look young let's go the beach this
is gonna be great
okay are we in it actually could you
take a picture for us really quick okay
thank you appreciate it
thank you we are so pixelated eople are
so kind they're not going to be like hey
your phones really old so let's take a
few more pictures and then wait for it
to be nighttime so we can get a night
test this is gonna be a shot with the
original iPhone compared to the iPhone
11 so I'm gonna go get in that hole oh
look so bad okay that looks stupid or
what I couldn't cut it look better
should I say like this
- potato well that concludes the test of
the original iPhone versus the iPhone 11
Pro max this is so fun it really does
take me down memory lane and right now
I'm actually filming a pixel verse
iPhone 11 so I may have already posted
it or I may not have so look for that
shortly or if I've already posted it
here it is right here a card or a link
in the description I will see you guys
soon I hope you guys are enjoying all of
the iPhone content I'm having so much
fun making it a huge thank you Tyler
who's filming and helping me edit some
of these videos and Jenna over here
she's been to moral support and the
phone photographer bad I'm notwhat
credit for this look it's pretty bad
this is what we this is what we had
alright that's it see you later
[Music]